[inaudible]
(silence)
[INAUDIBLE]
Can you hear me?
There you go.
Since you and I last saw that, I went and bought a new laptop,
so I'll try to figure it out.
[INAUDIBLE]
What's that?
Happy birthday to you.
Well, it's just easier to navigate
the job use with a laptop than a tablet. I had.
Um, like my resume.
I don't know, I don't know how companies do this, but I think somehow...
When you leave a company and they try to
I'm sorry, I can draw my camera on if you want to.
Like any files that you have.
that I had, like saved on my computer.
for instance, my resume.
When I download it, I'm like a phone drive. I can't access anything.
and then we'll see you next time.
Thank you.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
I'm sorry. I'm not okay.
[unintelligible]
[inaudible]
Yeah.
(mumbling)
So it's
Anyway, so that meant, so I had not, that my only word.
version my resume was on my
computer and then for that, therefore that thumb drive and I couldn't.
access as well. So I was able to find
when I sent my resume last September.
recruiter who was talking to me about the TFG.
It's in a PDF format.
So I was like.
It'll be a little bit easier for me to get this back into word using a lot of...
laptop that would be my clunky old back outlet.
So.
That's why I went and got it.
Now, I'm going to be a...
What's right?
That's right.
So how things going on you're in.
Well, yeah.
[inaudible]
Yeah.
Sure, I get it.
[unintelligible]
and if you want to see more of this video, please subscribe to my channel.
Yeah.
and have a good day.
[inaudible]
Yeah, yeah, I tried calling Dave Wolf.
the other day Friday and it went straight to the school.
male south. I don't know if he just doesn't want to talk or if he was
or whatever, but yeah, I just wanted to
Yeah, I could have just been busy, but I just wanted to...
you know, basically after Dustin, my anger has...
So all they just wanted to help connect some dots,
what the hell happened.
we go 180 degrees in seven days time.
So, anyhow, this is what it is.
(muffled speaking)
and not a separate video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, there's blue.
This guy is one thing and the reality is one thing.
You know, it's...
You get to the age that I met, the experience that I have,
you kind of continue.
down that same path in a perfect world.
you know, money no object, I wouldn't have anything to do with facilities.
But, you know, as far as reality and...
and understanding how Bill's to pay in kids in college.
You know, the...
And the natural path is similar to what I'm saying.
already done strategic account management in the you know.
facilities building space and maybe even a little broader
than that, I would describe it as, you know,
we're.
working with somebody centralized fashion who that.
responsibility for a decentralized footprint of buildings.
Right, so that's kind of you, that's the best way to describe what I'm saying.
I've done the last 17 years.
It's either been in utility.
energy conservation sustainability.
facilities, maintenance, right?
AC, plumbing, electrical, et cetera, et cetera.
And the most recently and the last four years.
months, right, the janitorial space.
So, you know, when I look at that background.
of that experience. A natural path is a continuation of that.
with a facilities company either a big
which is a big IFM, which is a big IFM.
you know, in on the what I call the cell side of the
business, right? What I've been doing, right, is...
is probably not that
big of an opportunity on the big real estate side but it'd be more on
on the side of like a 23rd group, a branded group.
You know, that's the third party integration.
aggregators, aggregators, of facilities made.
Now I have had a couple of discussions because I also found out that I have a couple of discussions.
with the experience I have in the cell side there could be.
be some value on the
buy side in the market.
real estate world, right?
So in
and expand on that a little bit.
Like if you go look at a cushion wake field,
a CBRE jail injury.
those guys. They have pretty sizable sourcing team.
And a lot of them are then they had these category men.
management. So, yeah, I've had a couple of times.
I got a couple of friends.
Good friend of mine.
I've known for 20 years.
He was most recently, he just started a new job most recently.
He was a senior vice president.
President's sourcing for Travis Centers of America before they got my
and then that basically jettisoned him.
him. So I picked his brain a lot.
about how what I've been doing.
in the last 17 years would translate onto the sourcing side.
of business and then I'm another good friend that.
I've known for, got at least 20 years that I worked with.
that Home Depot, who went to work, he's insourcing.
He's at Christian Wakefield now. He was also at...
JLL and at CBRE's been in all three and
He's put me in contact with some people.
people on sourcing. In fact, I have a preliminary interview with
weeks alone Thursday.
about looking at the biophilia.
side of what they might have.
So let's go.
a long way to get to the
the answer, the question you asked.
[inaudible]
Yeah.
(muffled talking)
First.
Yeah.
Yeah. And, uh,
You know, I consider it a little bit more.
little bit on the buy side going into
Not... not specific.
to retail, but using retail as an example as an example.
in facility management, director of facilities,
something like that.
only downside that I don't really not crazy about.
on that is in the strategic account management role in the FM side.
You're always an arms link from operations.
And at 54 years, I don't want my--
phone ringing at two o'clock on a Saturday night because
one of my retail sites is flooding something like that.
I'm like, "Amen."
I really don't want to sign up for that.
So.
Yeah, I haven't really, I haven't really, you know...
invest much time going down that path.
far it's more continuation what I'm doing on the bicep or something.
sell side and then maybe investigating a little bit on the
the cell size.
I got a couple discussions.
I've got a guy I used to work with at QSI's Chief Revenue.
officer at a company called Brand Point. He reached out to me.
wants to talk about getting into client success.
building out a client success program for them.
They don't want to be a student.
I'm going to go for one right now.
And then another company that I've talked about.
I've got a follow-up interview on...
tomorrow called Stratus.
Big commercial sign company.
So another place I have some people that work there.
So, my network has been what's been bearing the most.
for more so than just I haven't submitted.
I submitted one resume to one job I saw on...
link there and to me that's such a long shot too.
Yeah, it's a waste of time.
[MUSIC]
Yeah.
It is.
You know, you know, a job pops up.
You know, it always tells you right there.
LinkedIn. 125 people have already applied for
this job and it's like it's been up for 10 minutes.
Yeah, that's good luck.
Yeah.
(muffled talking)
[MUSIC PLAYING]
and then...
Yeah.
and it's all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's that's that's gonna be
I mean, I was talking to my son. He came on this weekend.
from college since his mom's birthday and I was going back to late.
the very first job I had out of school.
and went through every job that I've had and all of them.
We'll call it 10 in my last 30 years.
all but two were a result of my network.
And my point of view is that
trying to make to him is build your network. You know, use the fraternity.
that's the start of your network right there.
That's where you're going.
you're going to find opportunity.
And--
Actually, TFG was the first one I had in years that
that was not network driven.
It was the cold call from the crew.
that I picked up the phone.
Biggest day.
I mean...
Yeah.
It's cool.
It's like...
Yeah, certainly turned out
have to be, that's for sure.
(mumbles)
Stay.
*unintelligible*
(upbeat music)
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Yeah.
(mumbles)
- What are we eating?
And maybe not so as automated as your topic.
about but those are capabilities that you know the filters
within LinkedIn can get you to. You know what I mean?
I mean, you can filter by industry, you can filter by.
who knows people that I know kind of kind of thing.
It's a little clunky.
maybe what you're talking about is more automated, but
Yeah, I mean, yeah, it goes back to my comment about the
network. If I see something that's of interest, first thing I start
to do is find somebody that knows somebody that I know.
The C-TIG, to your point.
It's a futile effort trying to apply to jobs.
interviews but um.
You know, the network at least gets you discussions.
It's maybe--
None of this is going to happen overnight.
And, yeah, I think I'm way for love it to happen.
happen overnight, but I keep explaining to you this is a process.
You gotta, you gotta, it's the 12 steps if I knew.
job you got to work every step in process.
So, I mean, I haven't...
The way you described it is far more scientific, I think, than probably what I'm doing.
I'm sorry.
(upbeat music)
*unintelligible*
[inaudible]
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
[inaudible]
way.
So what have you done with that notion so far, that idea?
Have you put it to practice? Yeah.
So...
[INAUDIBLE]
[unintelligible]
Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(upbeat music)
Yeah, that's a hard part.
Um
Yeah, you know what? You know what?
Yeah, please.
say it like that and this this is becomes top of mind with
me because of my recent experience with T.
which is horrible.
It's impossible.
almost impossible I'd say to identify during the
the first to beginning vetting process, but even through the interview process.
process is.
What is the company like?
What's from a click?
And I hate culture as an overused term, I hate that.
But am I gonna fit?
And it's very hard because you're not, you know, the person
doing the interviewing and the person being interviewed or is not really shown.
Nobody's showing their true self.
So how do you...
How do you uncover what really is behind the curtain?
during the whole process.
I don't know if there's a solution for that other than
and how skillful you are at the conversations during the--
interviews themselves.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
[MUSIC]
(muffled talking)
[INAUDIBLE]
(upbeat music)
Yeah.
And you say that actually brings...
So another point that is always in my mind.
Yeah, I've lost my life.
I've been acquired, I think.
or four or five times, right?
So I've been in a company who was PE backed.
And so I've learned now what that means.
Yeah, you answer that.
That would be an interesting piece of the searches to understand.
Yeah, who owns, who's funding the company?
How long have they been funding it?
Right?
You know people are out in three to five years are they all?
on their fourth year of their investment.
Okay, well, you might expect there's--
going to be a turnover year in the coming year.
I mean, those might be interesting.
Because when you ask what size company,
we have a size.
I mean, I'm--
I've worked for Home Depot for many years in their corporate office and I've worked for a little...
companies that did $18 million a year and I kind of like
the smaller better, but that doesn't mean I wouldn't go work for her.
I like the small ones because I like being part of the
building and creating something.
I came to TFG, but I realized there was nobody interested in doing that.
(laughs)
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(mumbles)
Yeah.
[MUSIC]
[inaudible]
Bye!
And that is the one.
It's a shotgun approach.
Yeah.
I think I was talking to Jessica.
at the summit and we were talking about the calendar or
of the schedule of what we had to do that day.
And she was like, oh yeah, we've got the whole schedule.
Hills Hills team has to go sit in a room for two hours in cold call people.
I'm like, is that really a good use of your time?
But that was coming from me.
Victoria.
[MUSIC]
[sound of a bird chirping]
Yes.
[MUSIC]
Yeah, I'm a...
Yeah, like...
And a pretty example of, and I say this with these.
I've experienced these in two or three other companies.
is like the process around account.
development plans and how you build.
build your network within your client, you know, three up three up.
And I've been through this before and I've never seen it work.
It's always great ideas and like you said it's somebody read
a business book or just got out of graduate school and this is what they talked about.
about an organizational effectiveness class.
And so this is what we're gonna go do,
but I've never seen it.
It doesn't...
I don't see it applying to actual human nature.
Yeah, yeah. And.
Yeah.
(keyboard clicking)
It's a... yeah, it's not.
I have a...
seem to be effective.
[inaudible]
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't think that's hard.
That's right.
It's hard, easier said than done, I believe.
Yeah, which is maybe why you're here.
Yeah.
Okay.
[inaudible]
[MUSIC]
Um...
Well, I mean, I've got these comp too.
conversations this week.
with Stratus tomorrow.
and Kushman on
You know, I encushment on Thursday.
I mean, I--
I don't know how we would apply these two things
to what will your time.
talking about, but certainly if there's some way to use it.
use those in your test tube.
Let's, you know.
let's certainly try something.
Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Yeah, yeah. Let me know.
So if I can do that, it's going to be late.
I can track.
I got a job here and I got a two-hour drive.
I got a good--
me, my dad, and do his taxes.
So--
tons of do its access for an 82.
old man who's losing his mind is a nightmare.
So, I'll be out of...
I'll get for most of the afternoon, but maybe when I get back this evening or first
thing in the morning I can shoot you over a couple of things.
(upbeat music)
- Yeah.
Yeah, I'm like, yeah.
- I love that Stratus in particular, I mean, you know.
And one of the comments I worked for, we were owned by Kishma and Wakefield from 5 years.
So I have a little bit of understanding of the inner workings of there.
But Stratus is an interesting one to me and up for
for a key reason, and I don't think I've mentioned this before.
So, the stratosphere came in my radar because I posted on LinkedIn.
about me, you know, no longer tipsy.
A guy that I worked with 15 years ago when he was a crapper.
barrel is now at Stratis and he reached out to me and said hey
I'm at Stratos now.
I know where to go.
We're looking for a director of client excellence.
I'll share.
you what I know about it. If you're interested, let me know. He put me
contact with their recruiter.
story short come to find out that that job was never even posted.
It was never meant to be posted external.
So, I wasn't supposed to get it, but...
Because of another connection I have, the gentleman that...
I mentioned earlier that was a senior vice president of the
sourcing for Travel Center's America.
worked with the VP.
of people or whatever at school.
- They used to work together, trust.
So my country...
that's the end. So you got to talk to this guy. So he calls me.
and says, "Pologies that this is unfolded this way."
Here's the snare, but I do want to talk to you because you come so
I don't know a whole lot about Stratas.
But one thing, well I know a couple people.
Their CEO was the CEO of this.
Sility source why I work there and when I
They let me go because of similar situation.
They were--
about to be bought by CBRE.
They need to cut their costs.
He felt I violated my...
non-compete and sued me.
Yeah, so but I've kept
I'm not going to let that not pursue you.
Stop me from pursuing this opportunity.
I don't know if he personally pursued me the company
pursued me largely because they
had a lot of um,
holds objectives tied up in being able to penetrate.
Great Home Depot.
And--
I've worked for Home Depot for 10 years. I had relationships there before.
I ever heard of the facility source and I was still
talking to them even after I left there and they felt I was violating my non-
compete because of that. So from a culture standpoint,
point. I'd love to understand them and learn more about
down. But that's on me. I'll go do some digging. I'll talk to a couple.
people that I know that are over there now.
But I'm going into that in a little more volume.
(muffled talking)
Yeah, yeah, that would be cool.
Alright, I've got a jump.
Shoot me.
You've got my if you text me or email through something you
You have on your mind that you need me to take a look at.
Let me know.
Otherwise, I'll reach.
out with some more information that I can uncover.
Sounds great, Jimmy.
Good luck. See you.